all right, we have a segment on the program
called hatred.
Mail.
What is hatred?
Hate mail.
This is hatred mail.
We're so outright, it's wrong.
Hey, tread [inaudible] written by Patriots.
Who hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom,
right?
So I get all sorts of horrible messages all
the time from viewers and listeners of the
show.
We take some of the most outrageous ones and
they are interpretively read by a professional
voiceover artist.
This one is about, did David Pakman free innocent
blacks?
Take a listen.
This
who's David Pakman get he get our economy
going.
Did he secure peace in the middle East?
Did he destroy ISIS?
Did he get unemployment down to a 50 year
low?
Did he get employment to an all time high
for Latino, black and Asian Americans?
Did he have historic summit meetings with
low cam pools?
David Pakman, did he strike a historic trade
deal with China?
Did he free innocent black Americans being
unjustly held in prison?
Did he strike trade deals with Japan, Mexico
and China?
Who's David Pakman?
David Pacman's, just some loser on you tube.
Donald J. Trump did all those other things.
DJ T 2020.
This is actually a pretty interesting hate
hatred at mail and I'd love to, if I had the
opportunity to speak to this hatred, I would
actually want to say, what exactly did Donald
Trump do on some of those issues?
I go, what did Donald Trump get from his summits
with Kim Jong moon?
What exactly did Donald Trump do to reduce
unemployment?
And I think what you would very quickly find
is that on some of those accomplishments listed
by the hatred, I am about as responsible as
his Donald Trump.
Not all of them, but on some of them.
I think Donald Trump and I share roughly equal
responsibility for the so called accomplishments
listed there.
Um, make sure that you make hatred.
It's cry by using the coupon code hatred 40
when you use the coupon code Patriot forty@joinpacman.com
you save 40% and hatreds get really upset
that they're hatred that mail is just going
nowhere and helping to reduce support for
the show.
If anything, it's emboldening and inspiring
support for the show.
That's how I see it.
Anyway,